Hi. I'm here with Jonathan and Ryan again of Zipfian Academy.
And I want to take a step back before we dive too much into
detail about data visualization.
I really want to get your guys' insight into sort of the background of
students and what it takes to be successful in creating data visualizations.
So I guess for you, Jonathan,
what sort of things do you want students to now after their time at Zipfian?
>> Yeah, it's a great question Chris.
And seeing so many students work on so many projects here at Zipfian coming from
a diverse set of backgrounds I would say the most common hang up I
see with students is focusing too much on some complex analysis, or
optimizing some model without thinking about the larger process as a whole.
And I often like to tell my students your greatest insight is only as good
as your ability to communicate it.
So if you spend weeks optimizing a model to be 99.9% accurate,
but don't think about how someone might use it or derive some value from it,
it's basically useless.
>> Oh, interesting.
And for you Bryan I guess what sort of things do you think students need to
know in order to be successful in creating data visualizations?
>> Yeah I think data visualization is really interesting because it's
both an art and a science.
So, students not only need to know how to code, to work with the libraries, and
explore your data, but you also have to have a really good sense of visual
design and storytelling to craft something that's compelling to the audience.
We're going to cover both aspects in this course, in order to students to
think really critically about the visualizations that they create.
>> Great.
Thanks so much guys.